what's up everyone welcome to simulation  series my name is Alan Saki on I'm your  host simulation pairs together global  leaders with humanity's most  thought-provoking questions and in doing  so we hope to build a better world so  you as a patron can get involved and  become a member you get really cool  benefits like knowing who comes onto our  vodcast ahead of time you get to ask  them questions and submit them through  patreon also you get access to live  events early and you get to know when  they are where they are and you get  exclusive content among many other  benefits and check out our tiers to  learn more thanks a lot for being a part  of this conversation and we hope that we  build a better world together thank you